everybody fails at some things i mean
you know particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just
knowing about whatever maybe businesses
i don't even like the phrase
work-life balance i think it's
misleading i'm always trying to get
people off autopilot
like if you think about it everything we
do almost everything we do in life is
autopilot
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one embrace failure with warren buffett
how do you deal with failure and what's
your advice to young entrepreneurs
like me in this case especially with
regards to failure and how to approach
it yeah well if
if you fail you really do dust yourself
off and you know get right back in
i mean you're going to fail at some
things uh uh
you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out
uh you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced i mean
you know that's a very big decision to
have turn out badly but
uh i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history
and you'll everybody fails at some
things i mean you know particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and and
just
knowing about whatever it may be
businesses uh but
you know it it is not fatal i mean if
you're healthy
and you live in this particular living
in this country there's gonna be there's
gonna be an opportunity that comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school
uh when i was when i got out of the
university of nebraska you know
and i remember you know i went to
chicago to get interviewed this is when
you
traveled on the train and so i spent 10
hours going there and
this fellow looked at me and about 10
minutes he said you know
forget it bell and now i got to go back
on the train 10 hours and think
what what am i going to tell my dad what
i wanted to tell my dad i mean my dad
always told me i could do anything
and everything now i've just got just
gotten turned down uh
you know but it turned out that one of
the best things ever happened to me
because then i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact it probably
even affected who i married because i
took a one-year course at columbia and
said two years at harvard and she might
have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
well usually it's turned into a success
i mean it it
the world isn't over you know if you
have bad luck in health
that that's tough i mean that there's
just no there's just no getting away
i've been lucky on that but
but the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're bright and
you know you've got decades ahead of you
you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out
and find somebody else rule number two
harmonize
life and work with jeff bezos my view
is i don't even like the phrase work
life balance i think it's misleading
i like the phrase work-life harmony
because
i know that if i am
energized at work happy at work
feeling like i'm adding value
part of a team whatever energizes you
that makes me better at home it makes me
a better husband
a better father and likewise if i'm
happy at home it makes me
a better employee a better boss all the
things
it's not about it's not primarily about
there may be crunch periods where it's
about the number of hours in the week
but that that's not the most that's not
the real thing
usually it's about do you have energy
and is the
is your work depriving you of energy or
is your work
generating energy for you and you know
there are people everybody in this room
knows people
you who fall into these two camps you're
in a meeting
and the person comes in the room some
people come into the meeting
and they add energy to the meeting other
people come to the meeting
and the whole meeting just deflates and
those people just
they they drain energy from the meeting
and you have to decide which of those
kinds of people you're going to be
are you going to add energy um and the
same thing at home
and the same thing at home and it's so
it's a wheel it's a cycle it's a
flywheel it's a circle it's not
a balance because of balance that's why
that metaphor is so dangerous because it
implies there's a strict trade-off
and you could be out of work have all
the time for your family
in the world but really depressed and
demoralized
about your work situation and your
family wouldn't want to be anywhere near
you
they would wish you would take a
vacation from them and so
it's not about the number of hours not
primarily i suppose if you
went crazy with you know 100 hours a
week or something
yeah that maybe right maybe there are
limits and they probably
i've never had a problem um and i think
it's because
both sides of my life give me energy and
that's what i would recommend
that's what i do recommend to interns
and execs rule number three
get off the autopilot with sarah blakely
one of the things i also do is i like to
go up to people at spanx and i say
i'm always trying to get people off
autopilot like if you think about it
everything we do almost everything we do
in life is autopilot
we're doing things exactly the way
someone else showed us how to do it or
taught us how to do it
well if you're doing things exactly the
way everyone else is there's no
there's not going to be any real
significant change there's not going to
be a really meaningful
potential breakthrough so um i always go
up to people at spanx and say if nobody
showed you how to do your job how would
you be doing it
and i'll say just sit with that you know
i'm always like
i'll stop myself often and just say okay
you know this is how i've been doing it
but is this
right and give yourself the time to
think about it so i ask people to do
that
rule number four believe in yourself
with grant cardone
when i was a kid glenn i was like
i knew i was gonna do something great
and had zero reason to believe that
right like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not i think everybody has that
i would imagine that every kid
um has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother
uh he he would he'd be in the mirror man
he's like eight years old we're eight
years old he's singing
in here like he's a rock star right i
had to listen to that
all the time and and then i start
thinking
man man if he's going to be a rock star
what he's going to go on and be a big
rock star
and and and i can't you know because i
that
that wasn't my deal i said what am i
going to be
and then i thought i'm going to be a
baseball player i actually
believed i was going to be a baseball
player right dude i wasn't fast enough i
wasn't smart enough
i didn't have the arm i mean i had no
talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man
you're thinking too small when i talk to
people about real estate
don't do two units
got to start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32 right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too
sure if if you could just believe that
you can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced
transition on everyone hey man how you
doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five translate ideas into
products with larry ellison ideas
good idea there are a lot of good ideas
there are a lot of good ideas
there are a lot of good ideas
translating
a good idea into a great product
is unbelievably hard
there are so many details people accuse
steve of stealing
you know the macintosh from xerox you
know with the alto computer i was at
xerox park so i used the alto a lot
finishing the alto and turning that into
the macintosh
was enormously complicated and you
there are so many things that had to be
done that xerox had not done
there were a few good ideas in uh in the
xerox machine
but steve would translate good ideas not
always his good ideas
but he would translate good ideas into
finished product
unlike anyone in our industry you'd have
to i mean henry ford didn't invent the
car
but he made it cheap and he made it
popular and he made it accessible to the
american people
steve would translate good ideas into
finished
brilliant products rule number six
create
value with jack ma leadership is not
only about
inspiring leadership is those people who
join your company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure
in three years he will be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different
the products will never be different
i told many people when they join
alibaba
i say guys i don't know fortunate or
unfortunate to enjoy
alibaba we work much longer than the
others
much harder we had more problems than
most of the companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough we never promise
you will be rich you'll be successful
you will probably promote it but we will
promise
you you will be a problem
you have a wrong you will make a mistake
you have a terrible boss
we all promised so you set the
expectation
but have a good vision so that is the
way we manage
the company and i think
when you hire good people the good
people
believe the vision they were going so
when i visiting a company
whether it's a good ceo or not i do not
listen to the ceo
i listen to his people if the people
believe the vision
all the people believe this guy if the
people believe the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good a good entrepreneur
can always tell good stories i don't
need to listen story from you guys
i can tell your people right if your
people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision
he can tell me what they're doing
that is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to the toilet they talk their vision
and they believe it and rule number
seven the last one before very
special bonus clip is make better
products with elon musk
you want to have like a good competitive
forcing function so
that uh you have to make the product
better uh or or you'll lose like if you
don't make the product better and and
and
improve the product for the end consumer
then then that company should
have relatively less prosperity compared
to company it makes better products
um now now the car industry you know is
actually
pretty competitive uh so that's good um
and uh but and so then the the good
thing about a competitive
industry is that if you make a product
that's better it's gonna do better in
the marketplace
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
so you can follow through and i can
celebrate
you i was filling up my calendar with so
much non-essential stuff
non-productive things because i felt
obligated to say yes to lunch meetings
you meet this guy for 15 minutes we take
this call and i just don't want to be
like oh jesse is an [ __ ] he won't
take this meeting or so i would just do
it
and i realized like i was losing control
of my own time
and like i lost control of my own time
so i just said i started saying no to
everything canceling everything that
that wasn't going to really
that i didn't need to do right that was
other people putting demands on me
and i really started focusing on me i
mean i think so much of business
is a reflection of you and so many of us
don't
don't invest in ourselves yes so i drew
a little pie
chart of my time of how i want to spend
my time
and in my 24 hours i broke it up into
four different sections
and i make sure that every day i have
three hours for me
so i can you know because i think it's
just so important
that we put ourselves first and we
really don't
so many of us don't you get all these
arrows shot at you every day
bills problems friends need this work
the plumber has to come because this is
broken this thing won't start it's like
you're always dodging arrows right
there's no way around that
but if you don't take the three hours to
at least separate separate yourself from
the constant attack of arrows crazy
bonkers
[Music]
if you want another amazing video into
the minds of how billionaires think
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there if you don't love
it don't expect others will either
your relationship with time is such a
key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly